el presidente argentino pidió retomar el
diálogo lamento profundamente la
escalada bélica que conocemos a partir
de la situación generada en ucrania el
diálogo y respeto a la soberanía la
integridad territorial la seguridad de
los estados y a los derechos humanos
garantizan soluciones justas y duraderas
a los conflictos en chile y perú los
nuevos mandatarios de izquierda también
apelaron a la paz rusia ha optado por la
guerra como medio para resolver
conflictos desde chile condenamos la
invasión a ucrania la violación de su
soberanía y el uso ilegítimo de la
fuerza nuestra solidaridad estará con
las víctimas y nuestros humildes
esfuerzos con la paz
creo importante
llamar a la unidad de los pueblos en el
mundo
que los conflictos se desarrollen en el
marco
diplomático
que no se inviertan en balas que no se
inviertan en municiones desde méjico
amplio nombro las posibles consecuencias
económicas derivadas del conflicto
ruso-ucraniano nos vamos a seguir
conduciendo
promoviendo que haya diálogo
qué
no se utilice la fuerza
que no haya
invasión no estamos
a favor de ninguna guerra el espectro
político conservador de la región
criticó la invasión de las tropas rusas
a ucrania colombia rechaza
categóricamente el ataque premeditado
injustificado que se ha perpetrado
contra el pueblo ucraniano por parte de
rusia que no sólo atenta contra la
soberanía sino amenaza a la paz mundial
estoy totalmente comprometido con el
esfuerzo de proteger y ayudar a los
brasileños que se encuentran en ucrania
ecuador cree en el multilateralismo
y está dispuesto al respetar
y apoyar las decisiones que tome el
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas por su parte los aliados en la
región del mandatario ruso vladimir
putin cuba nicaragua o venezuela llevan
varios días expresando su apoyo a moscú